[Musique]
mais les vous de vos affaires ce soir la
protection qu'ovide 19 pour les
voyageurs randrianja un autre grand
assureur qui va bientôt offrir cette
couverture oui je précise d'abord que le
gouvernement fédéral continue de
déconseiller tous les voyages non
essentiels mais si vous choisissez de
voyager quand même il ya plus de choix
pour partir l'esprit tranquille parce
qu'effectivement il ya un manuvie qui va
s'ajouter en octobre à la liste
d'assureurs qui offre cette protection
covin y en a quelques-unes des sociétés
d'assurances la croix bleue manuvie à
partir d'octobre mais dippach tour med
mais faut faire attention parce que tous
une offre pas la même protection et il
ya eu juste une petite mention ici j'ai
été étonné d'apprendre aujourd'hui en
conversation avec le courtier
d'assurances sur et quand il disait ça
coûte pas plus cher parce qu'il ya la
protection coviva alors ça c'est la
bonne nouvelle mais il faut quand même
vérifier ce que dans notre couverture
par une certaine entreprise moi offrir
une couverture pleine et entière 5
millions $ pour les frais médicaux
d'urgence mais d'autres vont limiter ça
quand si bien temps de la colline en
fait si le contracté la maladie à
l'étranger balle à la couverture des
soins médicaux d'urgence par exemple
pour magnifier ce sera limité à 200
mille dollars par personne ça peut
monter vite remis à l'étranger les
dépenses associées à la quarantaine si
vous devez vous isolez lorsque vous êtes
à l'étranger ce sera couvert 150 dollars
par jour
et si le gouvernement déconseille non
plus seulement les voyages non
essentiels mais tout voyage mais là on
pourrait vous offrir le billet d'avion
pour le retour et les dépenses qui sont
associés donc il ya beaucoup de
conditions bien sûr aussi la protection
contre kobe 19 ne couvrent pas tous et
sapho faut analyser la situation là de
ne pas vous pouvez pas y avoir droit si
vous éprouvez des symptômes de l'aco
vide avant de partir évidemment donc là
vous n'y avaient pas droit
il ya toujours de conditions aussi deux
ne part pas de garantie d'accès aux
soins de santé et les hôpitaux sont
débordés là où vous allez vous n'aurez
pas de priorité l'assurance ne vous
offre pas ça et pas de protection pour
annulation vous le savez à l'avant ce
que ça existe la coved 19
vous pouvez pas évoqué sa comme raison
pour annuler votre voyage et quand vous
prenez des produits d'assurance et non
remboursables mais on me disait
aujourd'hui chez les courtiers
d'assurances tout le monde demande cette
protection là alors ça va être de plus
en plus populaires de plus en plus
d'assureurs sont appelés à nos frais
merci andré hommes attendent aussi
beaucoup